''Do you ever feel bored in life?'' //then stan talent stan bts//
YESSS! *chuckles*
''I've got the perfect solution for you!
Become a certified PewDiePie bro!!
For a small payment of five dollars a month you will
experience happiness like no other.
Or if you're broke turning off adblock will also do.
You'll be provided with the finest state of the art entertainment including horror."
JESUS! FUCKING!
*typical poods lol*
"Loud screaming shit."
*THE POOD SCREAM*
"Tits.
Anime tits." *poods starts screaming again lol*
"And Jeff."
mah name'ah jeff (stale memes)
"Lots of Jeff."
mah name'ah JEFF!!1!!11
"Subscribe today. You won't regret it.''
HEYYY!
How's it goin bros?
Family Friendly Felix here!
Is anyone still watching? *sad giggles*
Today we're going to go through some more
commercials! You guys really like the last
video so we're doing it again!
(stale meme incoming)
*m'name Jeff in many languages*
Now there were some objects that I reviewed in the last
video, they didn't make it - I didn't get
the items in time and I would just
like to review one of my favorite one
right off the bat, the booty pop
booty pop I've scavenged the internet I've
searched the deep ends and I got the
booty pop I'm wearing kind of baggy
pants today so I don't know -
family-friendly though... don't-NO sexual
intended okay if you look at me sexually
I want you to click away right now (please don't)
because it's not family friendly go
watch Casey all right there we go ( nice ass)
that's pretty good!
Dafaq is dis? oh my
god it's like a diaper.
YES!!
you can also wear it as a bra I suppose
how does it look? it does feel quite nice (It also looks quite nice ( o ʖ o))
I'm not gonna lie this feels like a
nice fucking ass I would love to have
this ass I know I sound like I'm joking,
I'm not joking this is an amazing ass to touch. (true AF)
it feels great. One hundred percent. Unironically, amazing product.
"It's here! Hollywood's hottest new trade secret!"
I get it. 100%. "side of bra enhances booty
pop panties are now revolutionizing
women's undergarments giving you sexy
curves in the ultimate list." (headphone warning)RAHHHHHHHH I've seen on
TV "Why is it no matter what you do the
view is never big enough for you it's
just all a big blurr" it it's just I can't
tell what it is it's all just a big ol'
blur got no clue what this is could be
Jackspediceye's asshole for all I know.
"A little bit like hieroglyphs" It looks like
hieroglyphs what you're looking at emojis
what a dumb bitch glasses have you heard
of them what you need is reading glasses
that's amazing let's see how he
reacts to his phone come on and it's just
like it's encouraging instant clarity
why were reading glasses with that you
can look somewhat normal in when you can
wear fucking working go look at that
look at that guy who would walk around
like that I would never been able to do
it without oh my god this is amazing I
would never have oh my god and it's
amazing my eyes I can finally see I can
finally feel this is actually really
cool do I look cool I feel like I look
real fresh real nice real tight hello
ladies zoom in on my fucking eye pimple
that came in yesterday thank you it's
style now from having my way the world's
first snap and hem
solution invented by a woman invented by
a woman gee I wasn't sure before I
don't like it when men do it but now I MIGHT ACTUALLY WANNA BUY IT!!!
magazine and TV shows are raving about
them so just tuck them in you can just
tuck anything in what's the point genius
it's NOTT GENUIS !! but here's the real
question if I order do I get two of them
BB offer absolutely free every fucking
time every fucking time they do these ( wat you expect )
they throw in two of them for no fucking
reason you know I didn't need 8 of
them I guess I need 16 of them if we go
back to big vision I swear they'll throw
in a double one as well protected carry
case free but I've hang on to help your
big bitches hang on hang on one
adjustable wired lanyard ok I still
offer really clear running guys together
beer oh look at that you get another one
I guess I really need two of them so i
can i can have a four hundred percent
vision so i can wear them double layers *pewds is shook*
you know what I'm saying every what kind
of sales trick is that if you subscribe
now you won't only get to subscribe for
free you get to subscribe again for free
you just hit subscribe and resubscribe
twice try it out it's free Lindsey
introduces us to the newest arrival to
the Magic Bullet family oh it's the
magic bullet I've seen this done many
times Ohhhh The babie's gonna love that! Enjoy! Thank you Aunt Marcie! * but the baby dosent like aunt marice*
where your gift? Oh me? I'm waiting for a special
delivery  oh my god the cringe *pewds lick's his lips for no reason* i wanna i
want to kill myself, this is good this is
good stuff okay and it's just in time
special delivery for Jenny why did you
ring the door if you were just gonna let
yourself in any way *ear rape* I wanna die. Special delivery for
Jenny! :D Oh come on and Mick just set it
right down there in the counter that's
what he did you fucking moron nice
package hahahah AHAHAHAHA (poods no please...)
come on guys come on in and take a look
at this gather at this learning me Eheheh you need to
check this out let me guess he's gonna
be super impressed later is the baby
bullet what is real have redesigned to
blade the motor and side into the
perfect combination for making perfect
purees for the best baby food making
system if you've ever seen oh I thought
it would be safe for babies to use I was
like oh so I can't stick my face in the
blender anymore well I'm not going to
buy it then it's a useless product yeah
he's still not impressed what is wrong
with him*viet-nam flashback* what the fuck almost 20 jars
and that's just what he's genuinely
bored it's not like he plays the bored
character the real question here is do
you get two of them call now and get a
second baby bullet system for free call
right now I need to call right now I
need two of them so I can blend
while I'm blending. whether you crack them like this
PAHAHAHAHA *catches breath* oh oh oh I wasn't ready oh my god yes who
fucking cracks like that you fucking
idiot HELLO from Wendy! And Wait until you you see what I have- (pewds cuts off)
I really hope this woman spent her entire
life investment on this piece of shit
product because I hate her already I'm
sorry. the easy cracker now you can
crack as quickly and effortless I just
imagined she she she was like I need to design a
product to castrate my man because he
cheated on me whenever I crack an egg
there'd be a mess on the stove
a mess on the counter well maybe you
just didn't learn how to do it properly. ELLO EVERYBODY (gibberish)
my new easy cracker,cracking eggs is a snap
just put it in the cradle and squeeze how easy is this
well we're going
to test it out we're going to test it
out because I have one I happen to have
an easy cracker right here very nice but
BUT (x100) Do i get two of them? Order now and i'll throw in the easy scrambler,just for you
OHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH I had this for a while I'm actually
genuinely excited to see if this one
works you can tell already that looks
sturdy I guess I'll crack in the package
so how does it work oh shit you know
what this looks pretty cool because it's
like separates it  someone definitely
stuck this in the wrong place you just
know that someone did that. no it wasn't
me okay it wasn't me this is the first
this is my virgin I don't want to spell
I don't want to make a mess so I'm a
little nervous Wow
that really worked (not) doesn't fucking crack
this just seems like it seems like a lot
fucking harder than just cracking the
fucking egg it still doesn't fucking
work what a fuck- YESSS ITS IN!!
also like an ancient trick I don't know
if you know but it's like a wizard you
just do this actually you know what she
makes a great fucking case I was
horrible you were right Wendy you were
right I was wrong I take it all back I
take it all back. leave a like and I'll if you
want me to do more of these things
really fun I enjoy laughing at
people making bad business decisions you
know, there is something wonderful about it so
leave a like if you enjoyed and let me know
if you want more check out my other
video that I did on this (stale memes intensify)
*rip headphone users* bye yall